bienvenidos de nuevo en esta ocasión voy
a hacer una aplicación acerca de los
sólidos de revolución sin embargo no
quiero que se aprendan solamente la
fórmula que construimos la vez pasada
sería mucho mejor que ustedes
aprendieran cómo construimos esta
fórmula y es que seamos realistas si
ustedes aprenden solamente esta fórmula
y pasa mucho tiempo ustedes no van a
recordarla sin embargo si ustedes saben
cómo salió esta fórmula y un día
intentan recordar esta fórmula tal vez
no la recuerden pero sabrán cómo
resolver esta fórmula cómo construirla
bueno tal vez en un examen rápido podrán
aprenderse la pero recuerda no es
importante aprenderse siempre las
fórmulas es más importante saber de
dónde salen pero bueno
regresamos al ejercicio que vamos a
hacer en este vídeo vamos a dibujar de
nuevo nuestros ejes y este va a ser el
eje de las diez y este el eje de las
equis y me voy a tomar otra vez la
función f x igual a raíz de x es una
buena función para ser un ejemplo de
sólidos de revolución entonces lo voy a
intentar dibujar de nuevo esta va a ser
mi función
f x igual a raíz de x no me quedo tan
bonita como una vez
pero es aceptable bien e igual a la raíz
de x este es mi eje de las x es el eje
de la 10 y ahora lo que voy a querer es
girar esta función alrededor del eje de
las x pero solamente un pedazo de esta
función recuerdan que si yo giraba esta
función me quedaba una vasija vertical
entonces yo voy a girar esta función
pero ahora en el intervalo 0 a 10
alumnos solamente voy a girar este
pedazo me va a quedar como un pequeño
vaso mirado mi lado verticalmente bien
entonces voy a tratar de dibujar este
vaso esto está horrible voy a hacer otro
círculo a ver este me quedo mejor pero
no no me gusta aclaró tengo la
herramienta de los círculos mejor voy a
utilizar la herramienta de los círculos
bien este va a ser mi abertura la
abertura de mi vaso de mi vasija y pues
cuando yo tengo que dibujarlo es ésta
esta abertura perfecto
esta herramienta me gusta más voy a
hacer de nuevo y me va a quedar esta
esta abertura
esta va a ser la boca de mi vaso y
entonces pues yo voy a dibujar también
la parte de abajo de mi vaso me falta
dibujar la parte de mi vaso por cierto
me funciona está girando de esta forma
por eso le puse una flecha aquí y
entonces ya tengo mi vaso lo que yo
quiero es el volumen de este vaso en
algún otro vídeo yo haré el área de este
vaso pero ahorita lo que quiero es el
volumen de este vaso bien pues para
tener el volumen de este vaso lo que
necesitaba yo hacer lo que hice yo la
vez pasada era agarrar un pequeño disco
y ese disco tenía que ver con uno de los
rectángulos voy a tomar este rectángulo
no no no de hecho mejor voy a tomar este
rectángulo de aquí del extremo mayor al
extremo menor entonces voy a decir que
este este de aquí va a ser mi rectángulo
y lo que voy a hacer es construir con
este rectángulo un pequeño disco
entonces bien lo que voy a querer
sacar primero el área de este disco para
esto el radio pues es la raíz de equis y
el área es lo que estoy subrayando
coloreando más bien entonces el área es
igual a pi por radio al cuadrado porque
son círculos tan de acuerdo y esto es
igual a pi por la raíz de x elevado al
cuadrado ese era el radio o dicho de
otra manera el área es igual a pi por
equis porque la raíz de al cuadrado se
van ok ya tengo el área de la parte
superior de la cara superior de mi disco
y ahora voy a dibujar mi disco aquí está
aquí está más o menos dibujado este es
mi disco es que recuerdan que mi disco
tiene una anchura de equis pero pues de
x será muy muy pequeño era infinitamente
pequeño entonces imagínense un disco muy
muy delgado con una con un ancho muy
delgado con un ancho de equis y ahora lo
que voy a hacer es sumar todos estos
discos pero bueno primero voy a sacar el
volumen del disco base entonces va a ser
el área que es pi por equis ya lo
habíamos calculado por el ancho por la
anchura qué es
x entonces el volumen es pi por x por de
x es el volumen de uno de mis discos y
el volumen total quien va a ser pues la
suma infinita de todos estos discos
porque recuerdan que la como el ancho es
infinitamente pequeño infinitamente
delgado es mi disco entonces voy a hacer
la suma de todas estas infinidad de
discos y esto es la integral y es la
integral definida entonces fijémonos en
nuestros límites los límites pues van a
ser de donde a donde estoy tomando la
vasija la base que lo estoy tomando de 0
a 1
entonces fíjense de hecho si tuviéramos
solamente un disco un disco muy pequeño
el disco que nosotros imaginábamos pues
la raíz cuadrada de 1 es uno y el área
sería uno sería pi y entonces pues sería
de equis pide equis pero en este caso es
la suma de todos estos
discos entonces va a ser la integral de
0 a 1 de el volumen de cada uno de ellos
sea pi por x de x y realmente esta suma
integral muy sencilla de resolver
entonces pues hagamos la de una vez la
integral de 01 de pide x dx bueno pienso
una constante y la primitiva de x es x
cuadrada entre 2 sí sí 'semis' cuadra
entre 2 últimamente sabe y oxidado con
las integrales pero pero según un
acuerdo si es x cuadrada entre 2
entonces voy a notar lo espín que es la
constante por x cuadrada sobre 2 y a
esto lo tenían que evaluar entre 0 y 1
acuérdense que no ponemos la constante
porque cuando nosotros tenemos una
integral definida no es necesario poner
la constante entonces solamente me resta
evaluar esta integral entonces en unos 1
al cuadrado entre 2 por pi pues son pi
medios y con cero que me va a quedar 0
al cuadrado es cero por pipo es cero
entre 20 y
y medios simplemente pri medios eso es
un ejercicio muy importante y muy
razonable que no se haya salido este
resultado a mí me causa mucha
expectación que el volumen de esta
función raíz de x al girar la alrededor
del eje 2x me salga pi medios este es un
ejemplo impresionante pero ya que vamos
a buen ritmo pues voy a intentar hacer
otro otro ejemplo de una vez voy a hacer
el área de una esfera entonces primero
pues la ecuación de un círculo la
ecuación de un círculo es x cuadrada más
de cuadrada igual a un radio en cuadrado
en radio que ustedes quieran
entonces ya tengo yo mi mi
circunferencia y ahora lo que voy a
hacer es despejar alguien ya quién va a
ser pues ya cuadrado es igual a la radio
al cuadrado ya esto le voy a restar x
cuadrada y si saco la raíz pues voy a
obtener que ya es igual a la raíz de ere
cuadrada
- x cuadrada de hecho no voy a resolver
este problema está muy difícil y tenemos
muy poco tiempo para resolverlo hay
veces que hago los vídeos de una manera
improvisada y me salen cosas muy
extrañas pero en el siguiente vídeo voy
a ver un ejemplo mucho más difícil que
este para no llegar a este este ejemplo
es un poco difícil y no creo que me dé
tiempo de acabarlo de cualquier modo nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo